good afternoon everybody and welcome to
today this afternoon is Frankie visiting
fellow lecture for the spring for the
spring semester I'm Gary Tomlinson and
the director of the Whitney Humanities
Center and it's my pleasure to welcome
you all here the Frankie visiting
fellowship is named after Barbara and
Richard Frankie who often are sitting in
the audience for these talks but right
now Barbara and Richard are enjoying a
warmer a warmer climate somewhere very
far from here one of our - Frankie
visiting fellows for this year is Steven
Mayer and it's my pleasure to introduce
him today hearing the voices from the
heaviness somehow it's my pleasure to
introduce Professor Meyer today he
professor Meyer teaches English and and
American literature and modern Italy
sorry English and American literature
and modern intellectual history at
Washington University in st. Louis his
specialty is traverse a wide range
including 20th and 21st century poetry
and also the relations of literature and
science in the first of these areas 20
in 20 21st century poetry
he's currently writing a study of the
work likewise wide-ranging of African
American poet jay wright and i believe
you're working with binding manuscripts
are there manuscripts here in the
Beinecke um yeah excellent in the binary
library but it's from the second area
the relationships of literature and
science broadly broadly conceived that
that his talk today is drawn he began
developing this area years ago in a book
on a Gertrude Stein that analyzed the
impact on her innovative literary
practices of her turn-of-the-century
training in physiological psychology at
Radcliffe and neuroanatomy at Johns
Hopkins and this work drew this work on
Stein drew professor admired to the
thinking of American psychologist and
philosopher William James an
anglo-american mathematician and
philosopher Alfred North Whitehead a
second book that that professor Meyer is
working on
alongside the study of rice poetry is
entitled robust empiricism z' jamesy and
modernism between the disciplines 1878
to the present it examines expanded
empiricist practices that have been that
have built on James's and whiteheads
joint approach and it takes in such
perspectives as those of Belgian
philosopher of science Isabelle
Stenger's French sociologist of science
Bruno Latour and British literary critic
and poet William Empson these interests
all have also resulted in an edited
collection of 2018 the cambridge
companion to literature on science in
which professor mayer gathers the work
of like-minded scholars working at the
borders of science and the humanities in
all this work professor Meyers sets
himself to step beyond the old two
cultures dichotomy and dichotomy OCPs no
not to deny the real differences of
snows distinct sweeping approaches to
the world science and humanities but to
reanalyze the terms of the dichotomy to
re-energize the synergies between those
terms and to understand the history of
interaction between them that reaches
back long before snow and his Cold War
atomic age concerns all of this is a
huge interest in itself but it's
particularly interesting in the Whitney
humanities center where one of our
signature programs is the Frankie
program in science and the humanities
please join me in welcoming Steve
environment so I want to start by
expressing my gratitude to Gary for
creating such a constructive and
welcoming environment at the Whitney and
were particularly for inviting me to
spend this year here before us anything
more Maria Rosa minik oh it was a very
close friend of mine and so it's kind of
awesome to be having her listening to me
right now this is the only place she
could be listening to me
but she might be so I'm especially
grateful for the opportunity to deliver
today's lecture which builds on the
Cambridge companion to literature in
science which Gary mentioned and which I
will wave in front of you just so you
see it it's
some fantastic essays and a difference
between it and what I will be presenting
today is they're all finished it took me
a long time to get them all finished
and but I am satisfied that they
possessed that quality and what you're
here gonna hear today is not finished so
it possesses a different quality it
possesses its own quality but it's a
different one so today's lecture builds
on the companion toward a large project
that I have not directly been working on
at all this year
which Gary mentioned a few details about
but which is always on my mind no doubt
even when I'm sleeping though I'm not
always aware of it when I'm sleeping
but I'm very hurt when I'm awake a study
of the joint investigations of the late
19th and early 20th century philosophers
William James and now for North
Whitehead who together with researchers
across the disciplines including
literary critic William Empson the
evolutionary developmental biologist CH
Waddington the mid-century American
philosopher Suzanne Kate Langer as well
as central figures in contemporary
science studies such as Bruno Latour
Donna Haraway and Isabel Stanger's form
an important lineage that I call James
II and modernism the talk will focus on
three practitioners of expanded
empiricism x' and gary mentioned a
comparable phrase chiefly the authors of
a pair of books that came out in 2016
literary critics Branka are such and
Angus Fletcher linked in the
presentation if nowhere else by recent
work of letters only the tour is
strictly speaking at James II and
modernist yet by a fairly unproblematic
stretch of the imagination
Fletcher fits the rubric and there's
considerable overlap with our Suches
findings if not so much with her
approach and I want to say again this is
because it's a work in progress very
much so I appreciate criticisms I
appreciate any thoughts you may have
even more than usual the title the two
silos points to a still broader topic
indicated by a couple of highly
suggestive propositions that may serve
as epigraphs from Emerson to put science
and the soul long strange from each
other at one again and from Fletcher our
hard task is to respect the song of the
earth now I should mention there's a
hand up at the door so if you don't have
it you can sort of gently go find your
wait can't what copy and I'll indicate
when it's relevant as you'll see this is
one of those instances where the hand
out is probably better than a PowerPoint
frequently organizational and
intellectual divisions in the Academy
are spoken of in terms of silos jargon
apparently imported from programs and
Management Studies several years ago the
Cambridge trained social anthropologist
and Financial Times correspondent that's
a column missus now Gillian Tett
published the silo effect on quote the
peril of expertise and the promise of
breaking down barriers close quote
easier said than done if experience in
the Academy is any measure given that
the broad embrace of interdisciplinarity
in both the humanities and the sciences
somewhat counter-intuitively might well
have made the situation worse even more
experts covering evermore specialized
domains of expertise it is still how
possible however to be a generalist just
last month I happened on a piece in The
New York Review of Books by Peter Brooks
you can see him right there the founding
director as it happens of the Whitney
Humanities Center he directed the center
between 1981 and 1991 and again between
1996 and 2001
the NY RB review was of a volume
entitled the storyteller essays which
collected Walter Benjamin's famous essay
the storyteller together with related
material by benjamine and excerpts from
text that in Brookes phrasing had
talismanic
value for him by writers inseparably
stitched into Benjamin's thinking in
addition to Nikolai les Gogh the Russian
novelist and short story writer
ostensibly under discussion in the essay
these included George Lucas Paul Valery
and Spock Johann Peter hybl Herodotus
Montana in somewhat leisurely fashion
Brooks presents Benjamin's argument in
the essay regarding as he sees it the
death of storytelling that might be
surprising to you the death of
storytelling and the concomitant art of
listening which followed the shock of
the great war alongside the fairly
traditional claim that quote death is
the sanction of narrative close quote
in other words quote it is only with the
end of a life that its meaning becomes
apparent
Benjamin's preference for the oral tale
over the novel is duly registered as is
the increasingly apparent threat to both
tale and novel information is Brooks
term for this the editors of volume
speaks of data we all know those terms
all too well
in passing Brooks refers to quote
Benjamin's sleight of hand transitions
surely the great gift that Benjamin
passes on to his readers guided by the
title of my talk you may have detected
some irony in the proposition that it is
still possible to be a generalist such
was the implicit assumption of the New
York Review however when I worked there
back in the mid 1980s and I certainly
would not have questioned it then barely
noticing that the operative criterion
for the generally excellent reviews of
popular science and of working
humanities that they be presented in a
manner accessible to the university
trained common reader pretty much
guaranteed minimal interaction between
the two silos there they were both on
the same page sometimes but there was no
converse
other than what you might register
reading them together more obvious was
how the distaste of the editors of the
New York Review for theory kept many
compelling developments in the Academy
off the pages of the journal with the
recovery of benjamine and notable
exception yet in one respect he was no
more true generalist than Brooks for how
much engagement with the science of the
day are you likely to find in their
writings that there has in fact been
tremendous overlap between the sciences
and the humanities in years past and
that this continues to be the case is
perhaps the great discovery of science
studies in the adjacent field of
literature and science over the past
half-century although like the discovery
of the Americas back in the day
this statement is at best half true
since the greatness of the discovery
only holds for the discoverer not for
the discovered who have been there all
along or almost all along CP snow was
dead wrong when he posited two separate
cultures literary and scientific science
studies and literature and science even
were pointedly demonstrate that everyday
yet there was and remains a long
tradition denying the overlap the
battles of the books between ancients
and moderns natural philosophers and
humanists preachers and scientists so
nicely described by Stephen Jay Gould in
his last work the Hedgehog the Fox in
the Magisters box now the three works
I'll be discussing today are all
examples of literature in science yet
aside from that they are quite different
the first are such is bird relics grief
and vitalism in Thoreau remains squarely
in the humanities silo the second an
essay co-authored by the tour and the
Earth System scientist Tim Lenten
doesn't mention literature at all
although it was published last year in
critical inquiry
one of the leading venues for the
theoretical humanities in the US it
identifies itself as quote a Journal of
art culture and politics there's no
science in that mix unless you want to
mash it in under culture right which is
not the whole story and certainly not in
the essay I'm going to be discussing the
third work the topological imagination
spheres edges and islands which the
title doesn't seem to suggest a strong
literary purchase right contains in fact
intricate readings of works of
literature although these are probably
fewer in number than we might expect
from its author who devotes a great deal
of space to the science of topology in
forming his speculations about human
existence on earth generically different
as they are I'll be proposing that the
works by Latour and Fletcher the author
of the third work Angus Fletcher cease
to be located in one or the other of the
two silos scientific and literary or
humanistic and instead operate in the
pluralistic reaches between them in a
pair of lectures delivered in 2005 in
Amsterdam and reprinted in the volume
the lure of Whitehead in 2015 Latour
introduced a related figure for his
preferred approach instead of building a
bridge between two shores a common
enough figure for interdisciplinarity
and also instead of inhabiting the space
between or around two silos he chose to
describe his mode of investigation as
that and some of you will be delighted
with this others will be somewhat
confused as a kayaker subject to the
vagaries of the river between the two
banks with this figure he reversed the
order of the various forms of
Investigation instead of escaping from
already built
or building a bridge between
pre-existent banks he was exploring
activities of the waters that had molded
the banks themselves before proceeding I
should note that there seemed to be four
general classes of investigation within
literature and science although the
field has developed in the aggregate
from the first to the fourth there's
actually no set chronological order
where individual instances are concerned
our search is therefore a good example
of the first demonstrating the influence
of science on the humanities that is
probably how most people unfamiliar with
the field think of it in its entirety
yet already by the late 1970s worked by
the tour and Donna Haraway for instance
had reversed the era and features
associated with a broad understanding of
literature were being used as
interpretive tools for understanding
science in the tour's case this involved
the role of writing in experimental
practices in laboratory life co-authored
with Steve wool gar and in hare way is
that of metaphor in crystals fabrics and
fields subtitle quote metaphors of
organa sysm in twentieth-century
developmental biology beyond these two
unidirectional varieties of influence
study okay the first in a second one
finds work that attends to the mutual
implications of the sciences and the
humanities no doubt and works like the
order of things fuku Foucault gave a
huge boost to such investigations in
literature and science proper this
resulted in studies that took as their
compass the idea of a single culture
which included both of snows two
cultures important works by Darwin on
Darwin by Jillian bier and George Levine
our paradigmatic of the second wave but
logically a monoculture is not the only
alternative one might take instead there
may be many ways of linking the sciences
and humanities none of which dominates
the others this form of multiculturalism
has a particular peel for someone
me who has chosen to work within the
framework of James II and pluralism I'll
remind you of the title of one of his
books a pluralistic universe although
that framework is hardly necessary for
literature and science to operate
essentially as an inter field with
multiplicity proliferating as it does
today
in any case read the book ok you'll get
a good sense of that in any case both
the tours and Fletcher's work works fit
fairly comfortably within that framework
and there is room for non pluralistic
investigations as well
as part of the broader pluralism so on
to grief and vitalism in Thoreau
this is a remarkable book and received
the MLA James Russell Lowell Prize for
the outstanding book of night 2016 so as
I'm using a framework again I want to
remind you is that this book and the
Angus Fletcher book came out the same
year not only did they come out the same
year they came out from the same
publisher not only does it come out from
the same publisher they had the same
editor they're remarkably different
books so I think that mostly goes to say
that the editor was in fact somebody who
had a very Catholic broad set of
possibilities in his head so I'm using
it that is to say I'm using our arches
are such as book as my example of a work
that despite appearances does not
actually challenge the two silos rubric
but because I'm going to be doing that I
want you to be sure that you appreciate
some of its many merits I mentioned
Peter Brooks his review of the
storyteller essays for several reasons
and one of them is that if as Lindsey
waters suggested recently he's in fact
the editor of both of the books
benjamine functions these days as
something like a patron saint in the
theoretical humanities this is surely
due in part to the romance with the
archive at the core of so many exciting
literary historical efforts and figured
for so many of us by the arcades project
several months ago
picked up a copy of 2119 in a local
bookstore Barnes and Nobles and and and
actually I have a question for you
because I realized I didn't know how to
say 2119
I think it's 21 bar 19 because there's a
line between 21 and 19 okay which is
technically a pipe computational
analysis is called a pipe or sometimes
it's called a vertical bar but the last
thing you want to say is 21 vertical bar
19 so I think 21 bar 19 might have
gotten this visual image across I'm
curious does anybody have a note and I
didn't have an alternative to that cuz I
realize I didn't know how to say it
aloud anyway okay good so I'm as far I'm
with the curve it's not ahead of the
curve so I picked up a copy of this book
it is subtitled contemporary poets in
the 19th century archive edited by the
Thoreau scholars Kristen case and
Alexander modulus and it covers similar
ground our search it just gets you a
sense of just how much this is of the
moment only there is so much more of it
in bird relics so let me briefly
describe the experience of reading our
searches book and some of the argument
early and Bart and bird relics she
describes her method which he calls
affirmative reading essentially she
wants to go with Thoreau as far as he
will take her and to do this see eschews
critique and judgment and more
importantly as she explains she finds
his quote strange ideas deeply
suggestive but that doesn't mean that I
have to believe in what he said close
quote
okay that's the affirmative reading here
effectively she reads him by willingly
suspending her disbelief okay as a tool
to take her places in other words if you
don't we'll only suspend your disbelief
this is what college was talking about
when he coined the phrase right you just
say that's crazy
and you stop reading and you stop
thinking okay we live in a culture where
that is of course the dominant mode
right and this is as far as I can tell
the only way to get around it but you
have to in fact then live in a world in
which poetry is part of that world
because for college at least right this
is how he characterized what he called
poetic faith which was willingly
suspending disbelief okay which is very
different from suspending belief okay
it's just about your skepticism and not
letting it get in your way okay so
Coleridge proposed this when you
encounter very strange material and
poetry such as zombies because many of
us encounter them outside of poems all
right now he calls us again
poetic faith Thoreau is strange enough
anyway all right but art just makes him
even stranger and strangeness is one of
her key terms she uses the phrase over
and over and over again and of course
there's a long tradition with that term
strange things happen in Thoreau
she begins that's the first line first
line of the book she makes him even
stranger because she has quote tried to
treat all of Thoreau's utterances as if
they were meant literally okay this is a
work against figuration anytime there's
a mean it looks like a figure let's take
it literally okay
now I take it that in this regard as in
a good many others arches is engaging
quite directly with the philosopher
Stanley Cavell who in fact if you when
you leave today you walk down the hall
on your right you'll find see a poster
for a conference on benjamine that was
in this in this building and he was one
of the speakers okay so it's a very
small world a great reader of Thoreau an
author before that of the classic text
must we mean what we say and so I take
it that artist is engaging that question
and saying with the row he means what
he's saying okay and he means it
literally quite amazingly reading
Thoreau in this manner it results in an
extremely consistent account
I say that's quite it's not what I would
expect if I stopped reading things that
are written in an apparently figured of
fashion and read them all literally I
would think I would be all over the
place not so in her hands
this is strange
except for another feature of our such
as practice for an addition to reading
Thoreau in any number of archives where
his voluminous manuscripts are stored
many of which have not yet been
published or she's has a tropism towards
the ones that you can only read in the
archive she also reads him by reading
what he read write fairly traditional
practice hers is a source study of a
very high order Greek dramatists
pre-socratic philosophers accounts of
Native Americans and this is why I'm
speaking about her book today more than
a hundred amazing pages devoted to the
very strange scientific texts to which
Thoreau was exposed at Harvard and which
he continued to devour into the 1850s in
these works she finds incontrovertible
evidence of his broad exposure to what
she alternately calls
vitalistic materialism and materialist
vitalism a strain of vitalism that in
turn focuses his grief at the death of
his brother John in 1842 which in her
accounting is the definitive event in
his life okay one might call this the
undertone of the book except that it
rings on every page the juxtaposition of
Thoreau's brother's death and the
materialistic vitalism produces in
arches single-minded but undeniable
reading a remarkable theory of grief
combining what she terms eternal morning
with a reframing of the traditionally
fairly sharp divide between life and
death so the two brothers continue to
shame to share the same material
vitality even as this continuity between
life and death is extended to any number
of levels of experience it isn't just
these two guys it's at all levels of
experience in the materiality for
Thoreau on her account so one of the
most exhilarating things about our
choices study is her capacity to find
similar claims in the most various
places until she goes too far at least
for my taste when she aligns Thoreau
with none other than Volta benjamine
even as she extends the figure of the
archive tweaked some to multiple levels
of Thoreau's world it's certainly not
the monomania that I object to obsessive
is another positive term that she relies
on throughout the text but with
benjamine artists and effect breaks the
fourth wall
so she manifest as she manifestly does
not do with the Rose own reading which
is limited to his actual reading
contemporaneous and in particular with
the role of science in her argument the
Darwin she what refers to is a very thin
Darwin 20th century evolutionary theory
is strictly neo-darwinian okay many
people might think that's what it is
there's a whole school literary science
studies that has been critiqued by a
faculty member very effectively yeah
which has a very thin notion of Darwin
that they apply to everything but they
are also working with a Darwin that's
long out of date she has no sense and no
interest in extraordinary developments
of the past hundred and fifty years in
the sciences of course she is not
writing about post-civil war anything
except that she is so at one point in
the book she lists a number of vitalists
philosophical vitalists whom she sees
coming out of the Thoreau vien lineage
among these figures she includes backs
are possible I mean not directly but
nevertheless maybe there's a overlap
there she lists Judah Luce the late 20th
century French philosopher who is
undeniably a vilest all right and she
lists William James the American
psychologist and philosopher whom Gary
mentioned so there's a problem here
James is no vitalist even if vericsson
is and de luces now are such expressly
identifies to Rose intense empiricism
which is a phrase she adapts from
somebody else and it's spot on
with James's radical empiricism and she
has a fascinating argument for how to do
that without I don't time to give it to
you and it's simply it works but it's
actually not James okay so see therefore
it interprets James so that he conforms
with her vitalism hers or Thoreau's and
remember it was supposed to be Thoreau's
only but at this point she's become a
spokesperson for this in a way that she
had suggested early on she was not
prepared to be moreover there is no
trace of Thoreau's brand of idealism in
twentieth-century developmental biology
there was insert precursor work among
his contemporaries not at least now you
this if you know anything about
developer ology you may say hey that's
not true there was lots of vitalism but
not at least after the new organicist
offered anakin in white heady and
inflected account in place of the
mechanistic or vitalistic accounts that
battled in the late 19th and early 20th
centuries now this of course would be
irrelevant head arches struck to her
stuck to her strictly historical
timeframe as she adamantly does with
science but not with philosophy the
discipline we're following Cavell she
locates the row most firmly so what was
happening in the early to mid 20th
century that put vitalism admittedly
more traditional vitalism than Thoreau's
to one side for that tale one only has
to look at the book by donna haraway I
mentioned earlier her Yale dissertation
in fact on the emergence of Anglo in
anglo-american embryology of what Harrow
a drawing on Whitehead calls non
vitalist Organa sysm now again I don't
have time to go into the details of this
but the following contrast should give
you a sense of what I take it has
happened in reference to a work from the
mid 19th century incredibly interesting
work by Robert hunt called the poetry of
science where he's trying in fact to
bridge the arts and the sciences it was
a key work for Thoreau so in reference
to that work Arceus writes science
around 1840
was of the opinion that the division of
phenomena into organic and inorganic
right sort of vaguely no breeze no sense
of what that might be didn't coincide
with the distinction between animate and
inanimate okay because everything is
animated
that was the science that the Thoreau
was reading so the difference between
organized and unorganized was not
animation but complexity but the or
organized and unorganized right are all
animated regardless so to get us get a
sense of how things had changed by the
1930s in embryology all you have to do
is flip it and so Whitehead developed a
concept which was then picked up
variously by the embryologists called
which he called organic mechanism which
was designed to sort of split the
difference between the organic and the
mechanistic but it was not again
vitalist right so so what does that mean
not vilest it means that everything of
sufficient complexity is organic
whether it's animated or inanimate so
it's exactly the opposite of the the
perspective that Thoreau would have had
in the mid 19th century
so again mice all I'm suggesting here is
actually there's a really interesting
conversation to be had between the
Thoreau of 1840
18:50 and the developments in embryology
which actually occurred in the 1930s but
I've only recently really taken off
because embryology was largely in
biology and developmental biology was
largely ignored within the modern
synthesis of molecular biology and so
this is a very interesting tale and
that's why the in fact her work is
fascinating so I have no doubt that our
artists is spot-on in describing the
extremely strange world in which the ro
lived in fact I am quite prepared to
accept that that strange world is also
the world we actually live in alright
there's a wonderful story that Bertrand
Russell used to tell or told in one
place about being completely shocked by
his close colleague Whitehead when
Whitehead said the difference between
you and me Bertie is that you think the
world really is the way it is at high
noon with sharp edges or I think the
world really is is the way it seems to
us when we were waking from deep sleep
and we then construct a sharp-edged
world ok and so that's a comparable
vision of reality to Thoreau's vision of
reality as as conveyed by our search in
her book but it is my objection to our
sisters argument is then that she comes
across as arguing for Thoreau's vitalism
rather than as she tells us she will
write spending a disbelief and so what I
would want to ask her to do is to
suspend your disbelief about his
vitalism but not necessarily regarding
so many of his remarkable observations
for there are alternate accounts of
these and which don't diminish them
in various ways and so if she took
science more seriously not just the rose
reading in science amazing as it is she
might take her commitment to what she
calls literalization she might you know
she might limit her her commitment in
order to allow a metaphor greater play
than she does I think there's a
connection there okay
now I'm actually I don't think there's
time right now so I'm gonna leave aside
I gave you two two handouts the first
one the cover of the handout is from a
1909 French Illustrated journal with an
article about the true shape of the
globe and so this is just an example of
not exactly a traditionally spherical
image of the globe and it is I found it
with when Angus Fletcher's first lecture
that he gave in this new project at the
time of his which ended up in the book
that I'll talk about briefly I this was
it was a lecture at the the the melon
that's our museum what is it the melon
Centre in LA where he was a fellow and
they had this picture in their
collections so they just used it okay
the second a handout that I've given you
is a a very rare copy of a very rare
pamphlet that was published in 1947
which by a friend and supporter of
gertrude stein's after her death her
partner Alice toklas sent Robert house
was his name sent him some pages from a
work of hers where he was in fact
talking about
where she was talking about him and and
so in this description that I gave you
he recalls a passage in a work of hers
called the autobiography of Alice B
toklas where she is
describing an encounter between herself
and Ezra Pound the poet who had moved to
Paris and was had had been a frequent
guest of hers at her apartment and then
on one occasion she didn't like him
she made this famous famous remark about
him that he was excellent
a really a village explainer which is
fine if you're a village but not if
you're not so she thought of him is just
basically a second-rate and but he
happened to sit on a chair that she had
a couple of chairs which are at by Nikki
the chairs are by Nikki and so material
culture and two children's chairs 18th
century French children's chairs and you
sat on one it wasn't very big but he was
too big and broke the chair and
subsequently the chairs were repaired
and I was topless stitched some patterns
that Picasso had had had had sketched
for her and so that's what you would see
at Vienna key
but before that pound destroyed one of
the chairs and he was exiled from there
there FETs and so Stein in this book
recalls meeting up with him the sign is
writing this in the third-person about
herself so he met Richard Stein one day
near the Luxembourg Gardens and said but
I do want to come to see you he's not
happy about his exile I am so sorry
answered Gertrude Stein this you don't
have but miss toklas has a bad tooth and
beside we are busy picking wild
busy picking wildflowers all of which
was literally true like all of Gertrude
Stein's literature but it upset Azra and
we never saw him again now how is it
literally true
they're picking wildflowers in Paris
it's a it's a just dismissing him with
something that I'd excuse right
literally taupe this may well have a
toothache but the non sequitur is this
other thing is not literal okay so I'm
just giving that to you as an example of
the complexity of the literal as a mode
of analysis this is much longer story
but we don't have time for that so I'm
gonna wrap up and and and just say the
the essay that going to present about of
the tours now it was anybody here at the
2014 Tanner lecture that he participated
just a couple of you several and so
that's the last time he's been at at
Yale and he spoke about how to better
register the agency of things and this
is in fact has continued to be a concern
of his and but it's taken a direction
that I suspect those of you who were
there at that session might not have
imagined
he had already delivered the Gifford
lectures in Edinburgh the year before
which were then published in English in
2017 as facing Gaia and he's become a
kind of climate science I don't know
what the word is I would say fanatic
except that that's the right thing to be
so we all should be such fanatics this
book however is not his strongest work
because what he was doing there was
training himself
while he was speaking to the public
okay and so that it's very interesting
but you've got to want to read it
it's not going to make you read it yeah
however in 2018 published in France in
2017 a little book called public
translated in English as down-to-earth
was published by fantastic so I just
it's a superb study of where we find
ourselves right now and so I highly
recommend it now the the essay that I I
wanted I cannot tell you strongly enough
how fantastic it is that was published
as I say in critical inquiry last year
last spring which called extending the
domain of freedom but why Gaia is so
hard to understand all right
and it's co-authored as I say it has
nothing to do with literature but the
reason why I would want to include it
under the rubric of literature and
science is because it's by somebody for
whom his literary engagements are always
in the back of his mind and they're
informing his engagements with the
sciences so you're when one is in this
form having to sort of dig fairly deep
but the just to put a just to give you a
little sense of what's involved here
because I really want to promote it so
part of the problem with understanding
the concept of Gaia is that it was
developed by two scientists James
Lovelock and and Lynn Margulis who were
working at opposite ends of the scale so
the notion of Gaia is important for
Margo's because she's a who was working
with microorganisms
whereas Lovelock is working with the
entire Earth and so they they're there
they're just so it just how difficult it
is to do genuinely a disciplinary work
when you're that far apart in your focus
so it's not that they're not talking
about much the same thing it's just that
it's hard for us to grasp it right it's
that kind of training it's that kind of
training also
and again because I want to stop and and
here's something from you it's that kind
training also which in fact Angus
Fletcher is determined to develop in
himself and hopefully in his readers so
where he differs so it would seem quite
emphatically from the tour is the tour
wants you to know this about Gaia among
other things it is not a sphere okay
in fact Gaia is not the planet on the
tours interpretation guy is something
called the critical zone and what Latour
was doing shortly after he was here ill
nineteen in 2014
later in that year I was actually at a
lecture a seminar he was giving and he
said to us I got it he is glee was
impossible for him to restrain he had
just been given a grant by the European
cultural association to run a consortium
of 23 teams of scientists in Paris
looking at various problems around
climate change one of which was in fact
the critical zone now what is the
critical zone okay so let me just I'm
gonna close on this but it is to give
you is just a quick sense for the tour
in with with his background that with
his training that he's managed to pick
up quickly he is describing something
that he cannot actually he hasn't been
sufficiently sensitized to it in as much
as he cannot see it as having anything
to do with spheres okay it is a critical
zone and not spherical whereas what what
what
Fletcher is in fact doing in his entire
book is trying to give us a way to
approach through the mathematics of
topology the way that that in fact
although we live on a two-dimensional
surface which is again it's not exactly
two-dimensional the critical zone so the
critical zone is maybe 14 miles but it's
it's it's almost as if it's a surface
relative to the size of the earth so
he's trying to give us a sense of how to
imagine what our experience actually is
and it's just - he says I can't do it
but he's trying to get us sensitive to
this the tour is doing that in his own
way and and but I'll stop there but I'm
happy to answer any questions
[Applause]
yes it's time something that is
[Music]
so part of that is I think the sort of
self selection of humanities professors
as such in other words if you take if
you take for instance are you going to
include Latour as a humanities professor
a lot of science studies is really in
this is another synonym for science
studies is sociology of science now with
what one of the directions that this is
gone with Latour and his peers is that
what might ordinarily be considered
obvious which is that the sociology of
science is about scientists because we
tend to think of sociology as a human
centered discipline but the sociology of
science is nothing like that as it's
been practiced over the last thirty
years
and the tour has been probably the major
person in in in in transforming the
approach and the approach is let's go
look in the lab and see how things
get done and give and this is the this
is the connection to his more recent
work on Gaia and see where the agency is
where it where it lies and the agency is
often in the interactions between either
the scientists and various things in the
lab or between the things with the
scientists only coming in at a certain
point so so that this is in fact so part
of part of the way I would answer your
question because I think you're right in
that in our training in the u.s. most
scientists come out of college
thankfully with a sense of acquaintance
with literary works and literary works
are actually credibly exciting things
and they can change your life and so
it's going to vary sometimes it's going
to be science fiction's just one of the
transformations in the field literature
in science was when people started
taking the effects of science fiction on
scientists seriously that is simply
opening up minds to possibilities that
might not have ever occurred to one and
but then there are many many other ways
in which literary works you ministered
works can so to take an example another
example Stephen Jay Gould who I
mentioned so Gould is a great
paleontologist and a great sort of
theory of theorize er of paleontology
right he has said many times had said
did say many times he could not have
done what he did if he didn't go talk to
his colleagues in the history department
who had all sorts of ideas about how
history functions within a human context
that he was then able to think about and
think with in OP in thinking more in
terms of paleontology fossils and so
forth
so there it's quite obvious and it's
bound to happen quite frequently because
of our educational system on the other
hand frankly and and and please correct
me if you think this is an overstatement
other than individuals who work in
science studies or literature and
science very few humanities professors
will have had a good time with the
sciences especially and again this is
something that's happened since the ROE
it's a huge factor oh the mathematician
of Sciences Thoreau was not a
mathematics whiz he was okay and he
obviously has fascinating things do
calendars and so on so forth so he had
an interest but it's almost always very
creative and now much of the really the
entirety of 20th century into the 21st
century if you're going to be engaging
with contemporary science of your period
you pretty quickly have to get
comfortable with the mathematics that's
involved it doesn't mean you have to be
mathematician since physicists are not
as good mathematicians and
mathematicians are or they tend not to
you don't have to you know the
mathematics you need to know you haven't
just simply been stunned into the
glories of mathematics as such right so
again somebody like the great example of
snow who was a physicist and was a
pretty good technocratic a pretty good
engineer and he in in in in in the two
cultures I say he makes fun of pure
mathematicians that are worthless so so
that's I think that's a big part of the
answer but it's not the case very simply
you know Gertrude Stein who I work on
was by no means a great scientist she
was well trained I mean almost all of
her courses in college were in the
sciences she went to Johns Hopkins med
school
and but I would never make a claim that
she's an innovative scientists but I do
make the claim that her exposure to the
sciences played a transformative role in
the kind of writing that she ended up
producing which nobody could figure out
excuse me please please please the
recommendation I believe she came there
she was very very medicine and she was
able to fly through the school just on
the basis of a reputation Howard Kelly I
thought the head of ob/gyn was the first
person who at the end of her obstetrics
training set
she-she-she would have to so I have to
beg to differ you want to know the full
story you need to read the chapter in my
book which is all about her experience
at Hopkins and neuroanatomy where she
was in fact that very interesting not
major work I would never make that claim
but there were transformations in the
field that she was exposed to that had I
believe a formative effect on the kind
of writing that she ended up doing now
in terms of Kelly there's a additional
factor that you didn't mention which is
that from every all the research I did
he was strongly anti-semitic and I he
would not give her a passing grade in
part because she was Jewish so and there
was a whole brouhaha about that trying
to figure out what to do and she really
wasn't interested by then she had lost
her interest anyway but she when she
started at Hopkins she'd finished
everything again as you said she made it
through except for one course at the end
and and she was at some level grateful
because she wasn't enjoying what she was
doing and it's sometimes hard to
persuade yourself to get out of a
situation like that but but but it was
not as simple as you're saying she was
actually she was actually doing
extremely interesting work and there
have been all kinds of
claims-made that people don't know what
they're talking about and so I would be
grateful if you would look at the
chapter in my book and see what you
think I have no reason to doubt that but
I'm saying it can't be used as an
explanation for why Stein in fact did
not do well with him interpreter you say
that stories have disappeared and so the
entire center of narrative medicine is
the story of the patient's lives
so one considers story to tell the story
to listen and it is they are stories
that cross between perhaps story
thing is live in the profession that
actually represents no you may not have
not heard me when I actually suggested
that I that this might surprise some
people in the room to hear this I was
using that as an example by a leading
humanities scholar who used to founded
this institution who was continuing a
line of argument that Benjamin had made
in the 1930s and now it's a more subtle
argument than that for what's involved
and it has to do with oral storytelling
specifically and a certain kind of oral
storytelling a certain notion of wisdom
and so on and so forth so it's a
somewhat different argument same words
but not the same thing Thanks
yes bye-bye your story about the Stein
chairs which I had never heard I've
never heard this cherries and to me
those chairs in this sit in a particular
space you know they're contextualized in
way that is almost entirely removed from
Stein and tells us except for their
provenance history I think they're kind
of they live on a like a tour of the
binding key and that's my primary agent
with them haven't really modernize for
very understanding what Stein was doing
this brings me back to you're almost in
passing description of the romance of
the archive
and I mister in your talk by the
trans-temporal
nature of many of these readings and I
and one of the things I wonder about in
in that is where almost all the sin of
conservators fashion where one fixes in
particular we how when it goes about
situating particular meaning in time in
much the same way that say when you're
going through to fix a building or going
through an archive to fix point you
might choose one period one shade in the
layers of walking burn as the point that
would she stop disregarding the others
also exist also iost Ridge and that came
out of the different he's actually it's
in the geographical area and he's
talking about how he and Wordsworth
divided up the poems in in in lyrical
ballads and then he says the way we did
this and this is the link in some way to
to our Suches focus on strangeness he
said I took the the subjects the topics
where you had to sort of make the
strange seem ordinary to the reader and
Wordsworth took the homes where the
problem was the opposite one where the
reader might think this is ordinary life
it's not interesting as a subject matter
for a poem and so Wordsworth's
assignment according to Coleridge of
course this is large very mediated by
their history but Wordsworth and Simon
was to take ordinary things and make
them strange and it's in that context
that he then starts talking about the
willing suspension of disbelief which
happens when you have something the
seems very strange temple identity of
how to read things changes so much I
wonder - just in John in John together
these different leaders in your argument
how you how do you situated the the text
that they were engaging with or third
reading itself and the within the sort
of archival framework that those ideas
might be subject to flux and that's like
that's an unanswerable question but I'd
be really interested just hearing how
you think about and he likes fixing or
reading particularly when moving across
time this way the earlier question of a
humanist reading science and the science
reading you miss because you know I've
had that experience of trying to you
know it's a very humanistic unist
trying to engage with Newton's Principia
which is just utterly impenetrable not
least because - because so so there's a
way in which one can read but it still
never
you thought about the specificity that
an hour Keiko perspective might require
for this kind of engagement with
meetings and it's just curiosity I'm
still trying to get a full handle on
this and you might explain it a
different way but the the overall
perspective here that and again I was
the the idea here and you didn't get the
full picture so you didn't get much
about about a Fletcher at all but the
idea was that you have a feel like this
could be viewed as a messy field where
very different sets of practices are in
fact utilized and what I was concerning
this paper was to say that some of these
practices engage with this contemporary
scientists sciences of the scholar okay
and some of these practices engage would
say the contemporary science of the
subject and in the in the former case
it's all kinds of creative work that on
many problems with the in the latter
case what happens again in the sort of
the present-day
situation of that scholar in relation so
it is it's sort of well let me let me
put it another way just might it might
be helpful so Latour
and and does extent Fletcher are
actually very concerned to I think to be
able to address your question namely
they think there is something that you
have to watch in the specificity of an
occurrence and of a life in the
development of a life that's not
predictable so they are in some sense
traditional humanists in the sense that
they want to be able to
get away from a deterministic model and
so that's the the the final answer over
the first beginning of an answer is
extremely careful work so that's one of
the exhilarating things about our
sisters book is that her engagement with
the manuscripts of Thoreau so one thing
she'll do so she's she she what what the
great reading she does is of a
manuscript notebook which Thoreau's
brother john started describing birds
and john apparently was dead set against
a classification of birds by species he
actually had a very you just saw that
that was that ruined the bird the
classification that was of interest to
him was the specificity of this bird
okay so what he dies he's has what had
this notebook and so this is a this is
this is a sort of thorough within an
archival setting even if it's just in
the house they shared so it turns out
the thorough after a couple of months of
grieving goes out with his brother's
notebook and looks for the particular
birds in order to continue the
description okay and that seems to me
it's i'm using as a figure in a way but
that's sort of closer to what you're
looking for then you know so it's not
something which one-size-fits-all but
that the the archive and so she does a
wonderful job with that it's just that
she my complaint is that she isn't
paying enough attention to them the
interim which includes from when she's
writing to when he was working and that
this changes because she actually does
in there all kinds of things in the
interim but the science is left out of
the indie interpret I said it's very
hard for somebody who's not trained in
specific scientific discourse and in
particular experimental protocols but
that's what in fact the best people in
literature in science again read this
book the Cambridge companion these are
really fantastic scholars and they
describe both the difficulty involved
and how one can begin to yes
and then Mike listen is you know whose
is whose James's right well who is James
and that would absolutely stabilize so
here's a probably too facile beginning
of an answer that so we all know how
astonishingly and brilliantly ambiguous
statements are and that they can be read
multiple ways and sometimes you have
writers who in fact engage with that
multiplicity and that's in fact the the
pleasure of the reading is to actually
figure out how these different
possibilities are all at play in various
ways but then you have right and and if
you feel that you're in fact engaging
that there is a certain sense that
you're not just projecting right that
you're somehow and last thing I would do
is say James but there's a there's a
corpus there is an extended engagement
of many hands and and so the the the
question I was raising there is my
impression as a James scholar but I
don't want to just that's my card no but
I'm just saying is that shoehorning
James into this list of philosophers and
then reading his texts a couple of times
in the book in ways that that seemed to
suggest that he's thinking along the
lines that she's proposing Thoreau is
thinking when there are many other
readings that are possible and this is
probably unlikely
that's that's the question and and and
part of it has to do with the this
giving example the astonishing ambiguity
of the term radical empiricism so this
is as a phrase is a phrase coined by
James there there's similar phrases but
the phrase radical empiricism as far as
I know comes offices pan now you asked
philosophers about radical empiricism
you asked literary scholars about
radical empiricism and know they're
likely I think still to think of that
something along the lines of the James
Ian sense the James Ian sense being that
empiricism traditionally emphasizes
discontinuities among entities since
data specific data and radical
empiricism gives equal credence to the
continuities among entities that's what
he had in mind by coining the phrase but
it is now a phrase that is in this very
specific history so again part of it is
you is actually trying to keep hold of
the this is the philologist in the
contemporary scholar trying to keep hold
of these changes so that at Harvard in
the 1950s the term started to be used in
a different way the phrase radical
empiricism it was designed in this new
sense to promote the the quite rigid
empiricism of the analytic philosophers
at Harvard at the time especially Quine
and the phrase was used to link the
analytic philosophers to the most
radical empiricist of all Hume whereas
James's coining of the term of the
phrase radical empiricism was designed
to take in purses away from him so it
seems to me it is possible to make such
claims that is we're not just you know
what do I feel is the meaning of this
here and it happens I got couldn't make
the argument but I could show you it
comes around the the
the use of the term sensation which are
such is employing in adolescent fashion
and in in Delors the term sensation
means a lot more then the term means in
again in sort of more rigid empiricists
traditional formats but it is not what
James had in mind even in the in the
Dillards in this is from secondary
sources about inaccessibility of
Principia that beauty was very afraid of
getting into controversies with people
who or did not understand the subject
very well and therefore he says
and I think you it may be the Metro
scientist please join us downshift
reception join me at thank you see you
bye thank you
[Applause]
[Music]